good morning believe nation today's
message is do what's in your heart over
to you Andre 3000 as long as you feel it
you know as long as you want to make
albums if it's in your heart because
I've seen jay-z and you know I've seen
Eminem and come here you know kill it as
long as in your heart and you want to do
it you know keep doing it I think
there's a difference between surviving
and putting out albums and thriving to
you know and just having the pulse of
what's going on I think there's a huge
difference so you just have to figure
out what are you really trying to do and
I got into it you know as a youngster if
you want to survive then just follow the
money but if you want to thrive you have
to do what's in your heart and so many
entrepreneurs they're just surviving
there's this chasing you one opportunity
after another after another and next one
that's gonna be the big opportunity that
makes them rich but you never get rich
because you never stick with an idea
long enough for it to become successful
because you're never passionate about it
in the first place because as soon as it
gets hard you're gonna quit and go do
something else
chase that next big opportunity every
business you get into is gonna be hard
and the people who stick with it are the
ones who love what they do and they're
passionate about it so you can either be
the entrepreneur that keeps jumping from
opportunity to opportunity opportunity
hoping to make it rich meanwhile you
stay in survival mode or you can thrive
by doing what's in your heart
so question today today is I want to
know a story from you about surviving or
thriving your own story a friend's story
I want to share in the comments below a
story of you just chasing opportunity
and trying to survive or actually
following your heart and thriving in
your company leave it below I'm gonna
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso